Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa
homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble, and fully self-enlightened one.
So this evening, well, let me tell you what happens tomorrow, and it makes sense.
So tomorrow we carry on till lunchtime, and then because the weather, it should be enough fine tomorrow by the way, the weather gets sort of darkish and cold, we might do just a small sit at two o'clock, but then hopefully we will assault the mountain behind us,
Yeah.
Not this one.
That one.
It's only 300 metres.
It's nothing.
Mark ran up and down it.
He said, no problem.
And then we come back and in the evening, just questions and answers really, whatever discussion comes up.
Okay.
And then on Sunday morning, I do a little finishing ceremony, breakfast and
and then you can escape so this evening really it's just tackling this whole problem of daily life you know how do we take into daily life and just use various ways that the Buddha talked about it
first of all just to get a clear idea of what the Buddha's position is when we compare it to other systems shall we say if we look at Christianity it really centres in upon the morality of things so you know the basic myth about Adam and the apple and
And then because of that initial mistake, everybody suffers and whatnot.
And we've all got this original sin, this sort of thing that has to be wiped.
And then it's a very complicated story about the role of Jesus and stuff like that.
But the basic thing is that we're caught between the devil and God.
And there's a lovely story of Job.
which all of you have read, of course, in which the devil says to God, this fellow Job, of course he loves you.
You've given him everything he's got.
You know, all these wives and kids and all this land and cattle.
He says, you've got to test him.
So God thought, hmm.
So he began to test Job and he killed all his wives and all his kids and
took away all his cattle and he's absolutely devastated and he can't understand why this has happened to him so then we have these Job's comforters they all come basically tell him he must have done something wrong but he hasn't and he can't think what he's done to deserve this catastrophe but the one thing he doesn't lose is faith in God the one thing he doesn't lose is faith in the goodness of God
And eventually God, of course, recognises this trust and gives everything back, a hundredfold and all that.
If you like the Coen brothers, their film A Serious Man is based on Job and it's extraordinarily funny.
Anyway, that's by the way.
the Freud simply took that on to a psychological or psychoanalytic level so with Freud you've got this so for a Christian it's this trying to know what is good and evil good and evil and this battle you see between the temptations of the devil and the invitations of God that's the battle between good and evil
In Freud you get a slightly different model where you've got this poor little ego, for one minute is dragged down by this animal id and constantly castigated by the super ego and the poor ego has to weave a little way between these two opposites and try to find some sort of stability.
I just general, you know.
From the Buddha's point of view, it's a slightly different problem.
Yes, all those things come up in his teaching.
The decision, you know, about what is wholesome and unwholesome, what is skillful, etc.
that the id, these basic desires, that our animal nature drawn to sex and lust and greed and then avarice and all that, all these things are in the Buddha's teachings.
And the desire to seek happiness in
in doing something good, that's all there too, you see.
So it's not as though the Buddha would deny any of that.
In fact, he would say that those who've understood that there is consequence for doing good and doing evil, in other words, the law of karma, they're actually on the path.
They're actually on the path, you see.
That's the basic understanding.
So you see, there were people in his time who would have said, it doesn't matter what you do, you can go down one side of the Ganges and do tremendous compassionate acts and come up the other side murdering and pillaging.
It will make a blind bit of difference because your life is set, it's conditioned, it's fated.
So that would be not in his understanding.
From the Buddha's point of view, the problem is at a slightly deeper level, you might say, as to why do we do these things in the first place.
And there he came across this fundamental delusion about who we are.
Remember that, having decided, having, believing that we are human beings, and heaven's sake, all we want is to be happy,
no matter how you might define it if you ask any human being what they want they say I want to be happy and they might define it in all sorts of different ways but that's what they want to be they want to be happy and that search for happiness leads to this acquisitiveness remember gathering things because the more you have of what you like the happier you seem to be you know the more money in the bank you feel safer etc etc
And anything that undermines any of that, of course, you want to get rid of.
So there's your aversion.
And if it's bigger than you, then you run for it.
There's your fear.
So there's your three basic attitudes of acquisitiveness, aversion and fear arising from the idea that as a human being, I can achieve happiness, permanent happiness.
You can achieve it in little bits, but then it always lets you down, doesn't it?
So, although there is at that level of working with what is unwholesome and wholesome, virtuous and otherwise, at a deeper level it's cutting through the very delusion that's causing it.
That's a slightly different model.
So the accent is on an investigation as to how these things happen, as to how we behave the way we do, you see.
And he wouldn't deny the role of guilt and shame.
He would deny the sort of existential guilt that might be felt within the Christian, Judaic and Muslim tradition where you are fundamentally evil and you can only be saved by God or Jesus or whatever.
But he...
That wouldn't work from his point of view.
But what does work is that when you do something harmful, then you dread consequences.
And there's your dread.
There's your guilt, you see.
Fear of being caught.
And the shame.
Shame is just not living up to your own standards.
Feeling belittled by your own behaviour.
And seeing yourself belittled in other people's eyes because of your behaviour.
So those two things the Buddha actually calls guardians, guardians of society.
He's not saying they're wholesome, but it does stop you doing things.
So you've got this model where on the one part it's an investigation as to our true nature and what should our relationship be to the world.
And on the other part, it's dealing with habits that we've accumulated, developed because of past wrong understanding.
And even present wrong understanding.
And we're still deluded.
Remember that the definition of deluded or delusion is that you don't know where the delusion is.
If you knew where it was, you wouldn't be deluded.
So we've talked a lot about the hindrances and all that sort of stuff.
So maybe it's also time now to talk about these parami.
Parami means to the other shore.
It's translated as perfections, but basically it's the virtues that we need to take us across the water to this island.
So the island the Buddha often uses as an image for Nibbana.
It's something beyond this present life form, you see.
So let me read through them first, and then afterwards I just want to talk a little bit about commitment, you see.
So we have ten qualities.
Now, in the Mahayana they have five, but in Theravada they have ten, which proves that we're better.
Actually, these were compiled later out of the scriptures.
I think as a challenge to Madhyama.
Anyway, these are the purifications, ten leading ones.
So there's the giving, or liberality, generosity.
There's morality, renunciation, wisdom, energy, patience, truthfulness, resolution, loving-kindness, and equanimity.
So obviously it doesn't include every virtue there is, but at least it gives us some sort of platform.
Giving is really the basic virtue the Buddha points to as a starting point because he points out that even thieves can be generous with what they've just taken from you.
They can be very generous to their friends and family.
So generosity is probably one of the easiest things that you can do because it's a matter of giving, you see.
And he always starts his talk to lay people with Dana, with this idea of giving.
And then he talks about the good life, and he talks about being reborn in heavenly realms and all that.
And when he's got his audience, then he hits them with the Four Noble Truths.
He sort of wheedles his way in, you know.
So I want to latch together these three great virtues, gratitude...
generosity and renunciation.
When we consider what we've received, you see, gratitude arises.
And it's a lovely feeling, isn't it, gratitude, thankfulness.
And if you go through your life and instead of thinking of how horrible everybody's been to you,
a terrible society and all that, and instead you go through and make a list of all the things that you've been given, even this life by our mothers, then very slowly the balance moves, generally speaking, towards gratitude rather than grudge.
And what gratitude does, of course, it fills a heart with the desire to repay, to do something in return.
And often you can't do it to the people who've done you good because either they've moved on or you've lost contacts, etc.
So therefore you move it towards an attitude of giving.
And it might not be giving what you received, but it's just knowing that gratitude impels you to be generous one way or the other, you see.
And generosity is either of our wealth or our time.
You see, isn't it?
Now, the interesting thing is that every time you give something, you're giving something up.
Because you could have used it for yourself.
So when you make a donation to a cause, you know, you could have used it.
Well, to have a good time.
And every time you give your time for the benefit of somebody else, well, you could have used it to have a good time.
You might have had a good time helping them, but it wasn't for you.
So there's that renunciation, you see.
And sometimes, when you give, you can sometimes push the giving just a little bit so that it hurts a little.
Because that little bit of hurt means you're stretching your idea of renunciation.
I think parents with children obviously have a wonderful opportunity because it's just like you've got to keep stretching they demand and you've got to keep stretching out towards them, giving moise so these three virtues are intimately connected gratitude, generosity and renunciation
Now, renunciation, remember, mustn't be confused with self-mortification.
In self-mortification, what we mean by that in Buddhist terms is that you sort of believe the body is at fault.
And you're almost denying the body its desires because the body is leading you into wrongdoing.
So you blame the body.
So, for instance, if you had a problem with alcohol, you're blaming the body, you know.
So, it's a case of recognizing that that's not what renunciation is.
Renunciation, in Buddhist understanding, is to give something up to see your attachment.
And you don't know how attached you are to something until what you have is gone.
And then there comes all these things that we've talked about with attachment, you know, the grief and all that.
So whenever we're generous, that's an opportunity to reflect on, you know, to actually make it a pure act of generosity.
So sometimes we, there are all sorts of reasons for giving.
You might give, I mean, you might do something for a business reason.
You know, that's fine.
There's nothing wrong with that.
You know, you buy somebody a drink so that they will, you know, sign the contract.
Well, what's the problem with that?
But it's not generosity in a spiritual sense.
We buy presents at Christmas for each other.
You know, a bottle of wine and somebody buys you cheese.
You know, a pair of socks for everything.
So... And it's just an exchange of goods.
I mean, this goes back to ancient times.
Kings exchanged goods as a way of just, you know, creating a certain friendship.
But that's not generosity in the spiritual sense.
But there's nothing wrong with it.
It has its purpose...
In our relationships.
The generosity we're talking about.
Is giving for the sake of the other.
Not for any reason.
Not for any purpose of return.
So we have to be careful.
When we give something.
And this is what we mean.
This is why this reflection is important.
So when you give something.
You give it for the benefit of the other.
And when that suffuses your heart.
When that suffuses your intention.
Your intention is.
complete and whole that's what's in your mind you're giving it for their benefit that's when you give you see so that the action supports the intention and that's your conditioning okay and we're conditioning ourselves to just give to just give now you have to be careful because after you've done that you see these little voices come up yeah you're truly a generous person
So you point to that and you say, ah, no, no, no, Mara, no, you weren't there, you weren't there.
Or one of these little underlying things, there's too much, get some back.
Or there's sometimes you don't reflect upon somebody asking you, like, you know, decorations, you had all this decoration, it went on for days and days.
And, you know, if somebody comes along and says, oh, yeah, I'll come along.
And then they go and think, I don't want to decorate.
You know.
And then they phone up and say they're not feeling very well.
And, I mean, you can't blame.
It's not bad to blame people.
But it just shows that often we give without a certain reflection.
But often, and we're coming to truthfulness, it's defined as doing what you say you're going to do.
Even if it hurts, because when you do something that you said you were going to do, and then you didn't want to do it, and you make yourself do it, and it teaches you, you know, next time you'll be just a bit more careful to say yes.
You don't want to make the same mistake again.
So this whole area of giving, it's reflecting on it, you see, when you give it.
And of course, you can do that with Christmas presents.
even though at the back of your mind you know that if you didn't give it that would be the end of your friendship the fact is that you can put that to the side and give something for the person's benefit so remember that intention is crucial your intention is crucial and the purer it is the better and of course don't forget you can be generous to yourself we have to also learn that I am also worthy of generosity
And sometimes you have to look after yourselves.
So the Buddha did.
I mean, here he is, he's liberated from suffering, he says he doesn't suffer, and yet he goes off into the forest to meditate.
And so they ask him, why do you do that?
You know, you're liberated now.
He says, no, I do it for my own quiet abiding and as a good example to others.
But notice, the first thing is my quiet abiding.
Like he's had enough of all these questions and grabbing his potty.
So he's off and he's, oh God, a bit of peace and quiet.
And he does it also to show, to be an example to others.
When you feed yourself, you see, when you eat yourself, you know, really say, really acknowledge that this is for our benefit.
It's not for my benefit.
I'm eating this for my benefit so that I can, you know, continue to live and live the spiritual life.
So it's very, you've got to be careful that you don't get into this thing about helping others and leave yourself out.
Because eventually it works against you.
I mean, you get this burnout business, you know.
And giving somebody who's a do-gooder.
See, that's the other side of it.
So a do-gooder, in my definition, is somebody who does you the good they want to do you.
Whether you want it or not.
And people like that come from a good heart.
But they're not really standing in your shoes.
They're not really looking at the world from what you want to do.
They think, well, this is what's good for you.
And it can be a real pain.
So, you know, the example I give is that somebody's ill, so you take them grapes and soup or something, you know, and they say, you know, thank you very much, but I really couldn't eat, you know, the soup, you see.
And inside your mind you say, you know, I've just spent two hours making this bloody soup.
They say, you could do something for me.
Oh, yeah, very good.
Could you clean my toilet?
I think I'd better clean your toilet.
I came here to offer you soup.
So, you can always catch yourself, you know, when you're doing this good and then you find, you find actually you're being a do-gooder.
So, how do we get beyond that?
It's very simple.
You ask the person what they want.
You know, you don't presume on anything at all.
Giving itself is a really...
Generosity is really crucial in our practice.
And it's a form of love, of course.
Generosity is just there.
And, you know, it's lovely when you see these... What do they call it?
Sports for...
Sport relief.
Yeah, sport relief and comic relief.
They raise masses of money and it's really quite...
Well, it's quite uplifting to know that people were prepared to, you know, to give, you know, for these causes.
Really wonderful.
So that sort of covers three of them anyway.
So it's the giving and the, I mean, gratitude isn't mentioned here, but it's definitely something.
Meister Eckhart, whom some of you might know, the 13th century mystic, who's very close to Buddhism,
If you read his stuff, it's very, very close to the Buddha's understanding.
He says, if you were to say thank you all the time, that would be enough.
That's how important he thought gratitude was.
Brian does it, doesn't he?
Just for today, I will be thankful.
Even he's caught on to it.
So, it's something to reflect on.
So, we've done the renunciation.
Renunciation is
You know, and it's just catching yourself these sneaky little selfishnesses.
You know, where you take just the bigger piece of cake.
You know what I mean?
You take that extra toffee, you know.
And then you just catch yourself.
And then you hate the person who gets it, of course.
So, renunciation.
Morality, well, we've talked a lot about that.
It's again, morality here, the Buddha's actually meaning just the basic things that you determine, not to go there, that's all.
Wisdom, well, we've talked about that.
So this is more of a mental, of a mind.
So a lot of these are heart things, like giving.
And renunciation and patience.
But wisdom is coming from.
This wisdom within us.
This understanding.
The faculty of wisdom.
Which is not to be confused with intellect.
Remember.
There's a lovely story.
I always forget the name of the monk.
But in those days remember.
They didn't write things down.
They remembered them.
And this poor monk he said.
When he learnt a new stanza.
Of the Buddha's teachings.
It would knock the one he's just learnt.
out of his head so his brothers advised him to leave the monastic life said you know you're not going to get anywhere so the Buddha hearing this went to see him and he gave him a very simple exercise of rubbing a piece of cloth and wiping his face with a clean cloth and just saying impermanence impermanence impermanence and he became fully liberated just like that it didn't work for everybody it didn't work for me
But it's a different faculty.
It's not the intellect.
It's not about understanding something.
There's one man called Putika.
What's his name?
Empty Putika.
There's another monk and he can explain the Dharma wonderfully.
But the Buddha calls him Empty Putila.
Empty.
Because he's not coming from experience.
He's coming from his intellect.
He's coming from understanding.
and people like that really have a big problem because they really believe that because they've really understood something that therefore they've actually truly experienced it so that's a lot to do with our honesty as well you see there's another little story about a teacher and all his students become fully liberated
And he isn't.
And he thinks, oh, I can't understand this.
And so he goes off and he asks them, you know, he said, you know, do you think you could help me?
And what the student realises is that his teacher's very conceited.
So he says, well, I can't really help you.
Why don't you go and see somebody else?
Eventually, one of his students tells him to go and see this little boy.
So you can imagine that's a bit humiliating, you know, how to become liberated
So the little boy takes him off to an anthill.
Now, in the east, when the ants have left, it's often the abode of a snake.
And so the little boy says, if a snake lives in that anthill and there are six holes, how do you get him to come out?
He said, well, you just stop up five holes and he'll come out through the sixth.
He said, that's what you've got to do.
In other words, through the senses, the six senses, by stopping five senses and just watching the mind, then you begin to understand, you see.
Well, of course, as all these stories go, in no length of time, the teacher was fully liberated.
So, don't get confused with understanding.
The Buddha actually talks about three levels of understanding.
The level of just hearing something, being inspired by it, understanding it,
but unable really to repeat it because it's not become your own intellectual knowledge and then once it has become your own understanding you can talk about it but then at a deeper level it has to be realized so you can talk about impermanence till the cows come home but have we actually experienced it at the level of me arising and passing away so that's the wisdom bit
Energy.
Energy... What's the other word?
Effort.
Yeah, you've got to be careful with this effort business.
Remember that, normally speaking, our effort is in trying to do something, trying to achieve something, which is perfectly all right in the world.
But when we come to our meditation...
It's important to realize that the effort is just to be aware.
Once you start looking for something or trying to attain something, then you normally end up in a hole.
Because even if you're not fully aware of it, there is some concept at the back of the mind driving this sense of wanting to achieve something.
So be careful with effort.
Just keep reminding yourself.
My teacher used to say, your job is just to watch.
Your job is just to be aware.
Patience.
The Buddha says this is the highest form of ascetic practice.
So if you think of ascetic practice as, you know, fasting for long times, or in certain practices, you've seen these...
ascetics in the East, even the early Christian desert ascetics, you know, sort of, like for instance, just holding up their arm in the air till it withers.
You've seen that one?
Have you seen that one?
Yeah.
So these sort of heavy ascetic practices.
He says actually the greatest of all ascetic practices is patience.
So patience is just a willingness to bear, you know, forbearance.
not only just our own internal pains and stuff, just not to get angry with things, not to be irritated, but of course with situations and other people.
So that patience is one of his great virtues.
And he gives the example of someone who says, if bandits came along and cut you from limb to limb, if at any time you felt hatred,
or a grudge against them, you would be no disciple of mine.
That's a bit tough, isn't it?
When I told this one, somebody said, yeah, the Buddha had a great sense of humour.
But patience is just a great virtue, isn't it?
Patience.
Truthfulness.
Here it's defined as, if you say you're going to do something, do it.
But I mean you can stretch that also to being careful as to what you say.
Even exaggeration is a small level of untruthfulness.
It's not being absolutely correct.
Exaggerating both negatively and positively.
And then there's resolution.
So that's what we were doing today, resolution.
Resolution is just that real commitment.
In the Buddha's life it manifested in his resolution to sit under the tree and sort of work the problem out either to the point of death or you actually work it out.
So you have to be pretty resolved to do something like that.
What I normally say is that say a course, you come on a course that you commit yourself to that course completely, right?
Acceptance.
You've always got to put a little ex-clause in because you might go overboard.
Accept in emergency or extraordinary circumstance.
Of course, you're going to define extraordinary circumstance in all sorts of ways.
But the problem with making too hard a decision is that even when all the signs are you should stop, you don't.
And then you do yourself damage, you see.
I know somebody who kept sitting and sitting with knees...
you know, with these knees business, you know.
And the teachers, my teacher actually, the Burmese would just say, watch the breath.
You know, sit, just watch the, you know, watch the pain, see.
Unfortunately, she damaged her knees.
So you have to be, you have to be slightly careful.
You have to go, you have to really suffer if you want to damage your knees, by the way.
You know, it doesn't come with just a little bit of pain.
You've got to work at it.
Then there's loving kindness, metta.
The Buddha often uses metta to mean all forms of love, which includes compassion and sympathetic joy.
Remember, rejoicing in someone, others, good fortune or success as our own.
Don't forget, all these things have to be also directed towards ourselves.
And then equanimity.
equanimity all these virtues do have their obvious enemy their straight enemy and their subtle enemy so with love the obvious enemy is hatred but the more subtle enemy is attachment and you can always tell when you're coming from attachment because you tend to be not listening to the other person or not taking their view or their desire on
And then you tend to get upset because they're not doing what you want to do.
You get irritated, you get bored with them, all that sort of stuff.
Whenever you feel negative about somebody, especially if you have a close relation to them, then you know that's a sign of attachment.
It's always coming from me rather than them or us.
It doesn't mean to say that...
You've got to be careful with that because you don't want to get abused.
You've also got to take yourself into account.
Anyway, it's a tricky area.
I haven't got time.
I'm going on and on about that one.
But equanimity, of course, is confusion, just to get lost in something.
But its most subtle enemy is this indifference.
Where you're standing away too much.
You're standing away too much.
There was a woman came to see me.
She said that every time she came out of meditation at home, her partner accused her of being cold, you see.
So I said to her, well, do you do any metta when you finish your practice?
She said no.
I said, well, that's what you've got to do.
I said, you know, when you sit, you want to be cool.
You want to be equanimous.
You want to be distant.
You want to be able to investigate.
But somehow you've got to re-engage.
You've got to re-engage with the world.
And you do that through the practice of metta.
Anyway, she didn't come back.
Either he gave up on her or she practiced a bit of metta.
So let me read out the way that it says in the commentaries.
As a great being, so that's often a synonym for somebody who is attempting to become fully liberated, or an enlightened being.
Are concerned with the welfare of living beings, not tolerating the suffering of beings, wishing long duration to the higher states of happiness of beings.
and being impartial and just to all beings.
Therefore, they give alms to all beings so that they may be happy without investigating whether they are worthy or not.
By avoiding to do them any harm, they observe morality.
In order to bring morality to perfection, they train themselves in renunciation.
And in order to understand clearly what is beneficial or injurious to beings, they purify their wisdom.
For the sake of the welfare and happiness of others, they constantly exert their energy.
Though having become heroes through utmost energy, they are nevertheless full of forbearance towards the manifold failings of beings.
And once they have promised to give or do something, they do not break their promise.
With unshakable resolution, they work for the will and welfare of beings.
And with unshakable kindness, they are helpful to all,
And by reason of their equanimity, they do not expect anything in return.
There we are.
That's a nice little standard for us.
So that's the, you know, just the little reflections on these paramis, these virtues or perfections that we ought to develop.
And the other thing is commitment.
So...
It really is a case of committing yourself to a daily practice.
Morning.
It's important because that sets the weather vane.
It sort of reminds you the level of awareness and consciousness you want to try and maintain throughout the day.
And then to practice that loving kindness to re-engage with the world straight after that, you see.
So that's important.
And then in the evening, that's the other time, really.
Specifically when you come back from work or definitely before you eat.
After you eat, you just fall asleep.
And the reason there is really to just sit.
And remember, you don't always have to sit in posture.
It is a good thing to sit in posture because it does help the awakeness.
But there, you're just letting the day come through.
So irritations and anxieties and all these things that have been happening during the day, just let them arise and pass away.
So let them pass.
There's all the cleansing, you see.
And then preparing for sleep, that's also important.
Rather than just coming straight off Facebook and launching yourself onto the pillar.
Or some exciting horror movie.
I mean, you've got to prepare for sleep.
I always think you need a half an hour where you just slow down, you can listen to beautiful music, you can practice metta.
It's just something just to bring everything down so that when you sleep you actually have deep sleep.
And then of course there's many times during the day when there's nothing to do, you're not doing anything.
in the sense of you're walking upstairs, or you're waiting for some transport, the bus or the tube, or you're hanging around waiting for a friend, or there's nothing to do, you're just sitting there.
And often what we do is we just let the mind wander, it's a kind of wasted time, whereas there are beautiful little opportunities to practice metta.
Or to, you know, some positive thought or thinking around the dharma or a particular issue or something.
But not to let the mind wander.
That's the awful thing.
Letting the mind wander.
It's alright when you're in a daydream.
But when you come out, we have to say to ourselves, now what have I been developing there?
What horrible state of mind have I been developing in that ten minutes, half an hour?
When I first began sitting, I'd sit for a whole hour going through it.
one fantasy after another it's unbelievable it hasn't got that much better but I mean at least but I mean at least it's recognising that the mind when you let it go it just is messing you up that's all and at Plum Village which is a monastery in France
It's the main center for Thich Nhat Hanh, who's a very famous teacher in the Zen tradition, Vietnamese.
They have this practice of having someone ring a bell anytime.
Absolutely, just out of the blue, just ring a bell.
And even when the phone goes.
As soon as you hear the bell, you have to stop.
And you have to wait for the sound of the bell to disappear.
It's a really interesting little practice.
And it's just bringing somehow that into our lives.
If you do work on a computer, you can get the mindfulness bell.
You can download the mindfulness bell.
And you can set it for every 20 minutes, half an hour.
We can also set it for at random.
It annoys me terribly, but I keep on doing it all.
there is a great old teacher anyway so this idea of stopping you'd be surprised I mean that was one of the great effects that meditation had on me when I first started so I used to be a teacher and you know you'd go out of one classroom I was in FE you got one classroom and you take whatever you've had in that classroom into the next one and by the end of the day you just felt ragged
And once I began this meditation, I'd used the passage from one classroom to another as a way of just letting everything subside.
It was quite amazing.
And during lunchtime, instead of hanging around with staff just chatting away about nothing, I mean, obviously, I did a little bit of it, but then I used to find a quiet corner.
And it was amazing.
The amount of energy I ended up with, you know,
at the end of the day was just was just well it was just a different my understanding of work changed completely in terms of draining energy you know and in fact all I realised was that it was me draining energy the work wasn't draining energy it was just me not behaving in a wise way so this constant stopping after everything you know after a phone call so you just reflect on what the phone call was you see it only takes a
It doesn't take long at all, you just stop.
And then you see, was the heart brightened by it?
Which is a good thing.
Did you become irritated?
Were you anxious?
You just stay there, just wait for that to fade a little.
You don't have to wait for it to go entirely, but at least just to acknowledge it and let it fade away.
So it's the same with meetings.
Meet somebody.
After a piece of work, you just stop.
After a meal, just stop.
And I think you'll be surprised what an effect it has.
So with this constant reminder just to be back into the present moment.
And how do you do that, remember?
The body.
Just go back into the body.
Come off the computer, come off the mind, come off the texts.
Just start coming back into it.
What are you feeling?
How do your feet feel?
What can you see?
What can you hear?
And that immediately brings you back into this
into a groundedness, you see.
And then from there, you note your next intention.
And what you do feel is just a greater control over your life.
Especially your inner life.
Not so much the outer life, that's to do with being in that matrix of relationship.
But definitely your inner life can be quite radicalised by it.
So we've just recognized the Buddha is coming from a slightly different place than our Western traditions of Christianity, Judaism, Islam and psychoanalysis anyway.
He's coming from a position of really that we're deluded and it's a mistake we're making.
And therefore our effort really is to understand what our true nature is.
And that's really the purpose of Vipassana, to see ourselves as we really are.
And then to see the consequence of delusion, even if we can't see the core of delusion, this idea of a self, at least we can see the consequences of it, which manifest in these
attitudes of acquisitiveness and aversion and fear and then all the rest of them and on the positive side to really develop the good heart that's very clear don't forget that the ethical life runs in conjunction with wisdom you can't separate them both and that's one of the criticisms of the mindfulness movement which I'm sure you all know about is that
Mindfulness is, you know, mindfulness and depression, mindfulness eating.
But nobody ever talks about morality.
It's all about mindfulness.
And I mean, sure, it helps.
Sure, it helps.
But, you know, it's like, and they won't go anywhere near self, not self.
I mean, that's taboo.
So it's basically pulling something out of its, it's like yoga, you know, body beautiful.
And forgetting that it actually belongs to a very deep and profound spiritual tradition, you know.
It doesn't mean to say that mindfulness won't help.
It will.
But eventually, the person will, if they want to move, they're going to have to seek something a little more deeper than just mindfulness, you might say.
Unless they have real insight.
That's possible.
Remember that a lot of the mindfulness movement is about suffering.
It's about physical pain, dealing with pain.
It's about depression.
It's about anxiety and panic and things like that.
Well, you know, there's no reason why they couldn't click, you know, in the midst of superficially, shall we say, dealing with an obvious problem and then suddenly realising where the real problem lies.
I wouldn't want to damn the whole process.
But it's obviously doing an enormous amount of good.
mindfulness and CBT cognitive babel therapy about 97% don't have panic again because they've seen that panic is the reaction to fear fear of fear that's an enormous success isn't it and 60% that's the figure I remember don't go back into clinical depression that's fabulous
And then, so, developing the virtues.
To be actively involved in developing virtues.
And then to organise our day around this whole idea of mindfulness and how we can bring that to bear.
Bring it to a point where it feels that we're pretty mindful most of the time.
That's a nice place to be.
You must try it.
So I hope my words have been of some assistance.
May you by your commitment to the practice soon attain the wonderful end of Nibbana.
Sadhu.